so I also highlight the contrast and the
Republicans who want to take us
backwards out of the country
deny access to health care 17 million
Americans increase taxes on the
middle-class tax cuts for the wealthy
that's the contrast that bad
psychiatrist so I feel like if I'm
talking to the head of the DNC I
how would you
the ads on TV and online that takes all
the Democratic candidates agree I agree
I'm a co-sponsor of the levy some
constitutional amendment that would
overturn citizens united and take back
campaign finance reform so is that
really the key to the whole thing if we
really want to you know really a point
that in order to make sure that you can
really how voters choose their
candidates and not have dark money in
fact that our democracy Opaques non
transparent contributions where
12 billionaires that are trying to buy
elections and then what are you doing in
the kitchen is where you're head of the
party so you have to raise things under
there real losers right and they can
just come in do anything how do you
battle it out I know this is sort of
insider stuff that people all I talk
about
they're not going to end elaborately
pissant while citing to make sure that
we can have a much more transparent
campaign financing process you know we
believe that we're going to follow the
rules as they are and we're not gonna
put our selves at a competitive
disadvantage so yeah we raise money
under the current rules while trying to
reform them and elect candidates who are
willing to support what do you make this
talk about by them jumping in because it
seems to me you have the Democrats have
at least two candidates that Stanford is
pretty different things but at least on
the same side
to a tragedy and his family which he
decides to get in the course he'd be
welcome there would be a certain amount
of enthusiasm for his candidacy himself
that's just going to add to the
excitement on our side of the aisle but
ultimately it's his decision it's my job
as our team at the DNC job to prepare
not only to get to support our nominee
when we have one to manage the primary
nominating contest neutrally